il ya des français qui sont des français
de bonne volonté qui vont devoir prendre
des dizaines de milliers de décisions
chaque jour pour le déconfinement il
faut leur dire pour qu'ils puissent le
faire de bon coeur en toute sécurité que
ces décisions ne le sont ne leur seront
pas mises à charge à eux
elles seront mises à charge de ceux qui
en réalité ont défini le système et ont
décidé des moyens à mettre en oeuvre
autrement dit je ne veux pas moi d'un
dispositif qui permettrait de poursuivre
les petits et de protéger les puissants
je ne veux pas d'un dispositif qui
permettrait de clarifier la
responsabilité pénale du directeur
d'école du maire du responsable d'une
petite unité de production et qui en
profiterait pour créer une forme
d'exonération de responsabilité pour le
ministre pour le préfet pour le
directeur d' agences régionales de santé
qui eux et fixant des règles pour vous
autrement dit quand un maire un chef
d'atelier un directeur d'école respecte
les obligations particulières de
prudence qui sont prévues par les lois
et les règlements qui ont été mises en
place pour lutter contre le vide 19
je ne vois pas pourquoi on lui ferait
courir un risque pénal
en revanche ce qui pose les règles il ne
s'agit pas de les mettre à l'abri
je crains malheureusement et c'est une
analyse juridique qui est partagé par
beaucoup de juristes que l'amendement
qui vient d'être adoptée à la commission
des lois de l'assemblée nationale ne
respectent pas ces conditions et nous
aurons l'occasion d'en discuter parce
que je suis convaincu que c'est un
volontairement parce que je n'imagine
pas que quiconque voudrait protéger ceux
qui sont les décideurs et non pas ceux
qui sont ceux qui vont appliquer sur le
terrain les mesures de déconfinement
très rapidement vous êtes optimiste pour
la commission mixte paritaire
je suis toujours optimiste parce que je
pense que le débat permet tout
pour de faire progresser une vision
partagée de l'intérêt général et nous
sommes dans une période de la vie
publique où chacun doit prendre ses
responsabilités et bien merci beau